it's true when you're a young artist and
you're trying to make it and uh you know
the documentary really brought it home
for me this guy uh frank deleo we're
talking about was michael jackson's
manager
he had the hearts for you these guys
they're such bullies they they know how
to manipulate situations whether it's
with men or women they know how to zero
in on your weaknesses and you know you
were strong enough to say no you could
see where a lot of women would say yes
because they just you want you want to
be successful and you start to buy the
dream and that's probably the most
heartbreaking thing i was pretty um
disappointed with the the idea that you
know i grew up in the midwest my parents
really you know puritan work ethic you
work hard you're a nice person put one
foot in front of the other and i just
thought that that was
i thought good things would happen you
would think after you did that tour with
michael jackson right you've arrived
like wow you're right you're performing
in front of millions of people you're
performing michael jackson there's
rumors that you're dating him and all
this stuff i saw this in the documentary
it's so great two million dollars to
have his baby yeah exactly
and you were the girl who was with
michael jackson which they probably put
out to make them
yeah
yeah but after that tour was over you
went back to your waitressing job yeah
like that's the reality of show business
it's such a crazy scene
that whole thing though i mean you know
um well there's a whole backstory to
that with
having his manager
take that notoriety that i was accruing
and
you know trying to
architect some
some pop career around me and i didn't
want to be a pop star and then the
sexual harassment was involved in all
that and then the threat of you're never
going to work
and my going home and
putting bands together and playing my
music and having everybody in the
industry say well we don't know what to
do with a blue blue-eyed soul singer or
you know i got a ton of excuses and
i just felt like it was all
tied together like the word was out
frank had sabotaged me and
also there wasn't you know
it was lisa elise and the cult jam and
madonna and paul abdul and i came off
the jackson tour and i wasn't that
and i eventually went through the money
and got waiting
you know waiter jobs and
went back to what i was doing before and
it was it was it was tough it was really
tough i mean it's tough coming off the
road
and just sinking back into your own life
no matter what
but that was that was some other kind of
tough
you